Bruce says, Jeff, in the beginning, you mentioned just using your ad account for the first 10 or 15 campaigns before using an MCC.
So my question is, I already have an ad account set up under my name. It is season three plus years. I use it for affiliate marketing so it is not an MCC account.
Would you suggest that I just go ahead with that account for now and transition over to an MCC account down the road?
That's the first question.
So if all of your ads, if you go and you click your icon in the top and you see all of your ads, your Google ads that drop down from that, if you can manage them from there, I would just say I wouldn't mess with it.
But if you, for whatever reason, if you want to create the hierarchy of an MCC, and then moving them all in there, you can, but what might happen is that because all of those got set up under that one, you might have some issues like setting them up separately.
So you can set that up, you can set up an MCC, you can add an account, you should be able to migrate each of those individual ad numbers and bring them in.
Is it necessary? No.
So if you're going to start growing, you want to do it? Yes, you can. What I would say is I would start a different account as an MCC account and bring those over because then it actually creates a legit hierarchy.
That's, you know, Jeff 123 versus my old one, which is Jeff 456. Does that make sense?
Then his second part, I think you just answered. Secondly, when it is time to transition, should I open a new account under my agency name and set up the MCC account there, by the way, thanks for what you do.
Yes, if you're, so you're not that it's necessary, but if you have like an account, like a, like a domain, you register with Google and you're doing like a, you know, domain match email type of thing, then that's the one you want to set up.
And there's a verification process to go through. And, but that's when you're like, you're running a legit business, like you've made enough money to start doing that. So if you're going to do it, that's how I would do it.
Your second part is that's what I would do and suggest, but it's not necessary for what we're doing. It's just like when you start getting the next level, that's why I said 15 or 20. When you start getting beyond that, it's, it's, it is a pain in the ass. I get it.
But yeah, to drop. Yeah, for sure.